i've noticed that sometimes they're
america when we have a holiday we really
commercialize it and make it
you know what i'm saying we like
halloween for example i don't know what
they do about halloween
in england here of course it's all about
candy and
you know i mean they've practically
turned it into christmas what's it like
growing up in england we're about to
have halloween so my kids say it's their
number one holiday before christmas now
my kids love it i actually love it yeah
when i grew up it was basically
considered evil
so so you didn't i don't even know if i
could have said the word for a while
really i thought if i if we even like
carve a pumpkin i might you know go to
hell
and
and so i grew up with that mindset and
then we came here like oh maybe there's
a different way of looking at it yeah
that's so crazy they really take the
whole like hallows eve spirits darkness
thing very seriously there whereas here
we're just like have a twix bar relax
man well you know i think i think we're
not to get too serious but i think it
was based on a on a pagan sort of
harvest festival right it was as you
know you've read wikipedia yeah um
that's where i get all my knowledge so
and then and then i think some people
decided they didn't want people to
celebrate so they made it sort of evil
where i come from that sort of lingered
on like this is an evil festival and if
you're holding a pumpkin you're going to
burn for eternity oh my god no no i
couldn't even eat pumpkin till i was 36.
[Laughter]
you europeans you screw up your holidays
so badly you know we we sometimes get
things wrong but we have great chocolate
and nice people no
all right okay i'll let that go for now